कि नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में कि
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है आज हम
सीखने वाले हैं रिप्लेस के वर्क अब यह
इफेक्टिव वर्क कंसेप्ट है यह थोड़ी सी
समझने के लिए मुश्किल है क्योंकि यह थोड़ी
सी यूरोपीयन लैंग्वेजेस की कंसेप्ट है
मतलब फॉर एग्जांपल जगह इंग्लिश में बोलते
हैं आइए इंट्रोड्यूस माइक सैलरी या ही
इंट्रोड्यूस हिमसेल्फ टू जगलाल तो इसमें
जो यह माइसेल्फ हिमसेल्फ है वगैरह जो है
वह कैन अफेक्ट यू प्रोनाउंस है और यह के
मुहूर्त के साथ आते हैं उनको साइंटिफिक
सिर्फ उस अब हम बोल सकते हैं मैं अभी जो
आज और खुद इटालियन और स्पेनिश भी सीख रहा
हूं उनमें भी यह बहुत होते हैं स्पेनिश
में वह सिर्फ है इंटर देते हैं इटालियन
में उसी से एंड होते हैं ओके तो इन जर्मन
और उसको देना लौटे मिनट इंग्लिश में ही वह
कम है अनफॉर्चूनेटली र फर्स्ट यह हमारी
इंडियन भाषाओं में वह कम है तो थोड़ा सा
यह कंसेप्ट समझने के लिए
नई दिल्ली हाल है पर इसीलिए उसको में इजी
करके सीखेंगे तो सबसे पहले आपको
इन्फ्लिक्ट वर्ड्स रिफ्लेक्ट वर्ग फुट
करते हैं इसमें करता जो है और कर्म
सब्जेक्ट एंड ऑब्जेक्ट है वह रिलेटेड है
या फिर सेम है तो जैसे मैंने बोला कि आई
इंट्रोड्यूस माइक शैल या फिर इन सुच केसेस
बट ट्रस्ट मे ही स्पेशल इन जर्मन इन उसकी
स्थिति सब्सिडी हार्ट कंडीशन हम अब बाद
में बात करेंगे तो आपको पता चलेगा तो इसी
लिए एक कंसेप्ट मैं आपको बोलूंगा कि थोड़ा
सा आपको याद ही रखना पड़ेगा तो इसके दो
पार्ट करते हैं सबसे पहले जो हमने इंग्लिश
में माइसेल्फ योरसेल्फ रिम्स देखा था वह
इन जर्मन में क्या है वह देखते हैं तो
कबीर टेबल दिख रहा होगा तो आपको यह बलगम
पहचानता लग रहा होगा अगर हम अपने इष्ट
नियर एपिसोड देखा है तो अगर नहीं देखा है
तो जाकर
वो कंसेप्ट ईयर करके आओ इस मिश्रण अप आपको
जटिल होते हो तो मिल सकते हो अपडेट होते
हो तो आप नियर होते हो वह अगर कम सिर्फ
क्लियर है तो वह और यह टेबल SIM है सिर्फ
क्या है जब मैं इसको यूज किया है कि वह
एड्रेस जहां था वह सिर्फ ईश्वर जहां-जहां
एग्री था वहां पर ईश्वर बाकी सब नॉर्मल है
इस मिश्र दीजिए और बीयर के लिए हेयर के
लिए सेम है उसके कारण और फायदा क्या हुआ
है रिक्वायर्ड टेबल ठीक से देखोगे सिर्फ
इस और दूं के लिए अकाट्य डिफरेंट है बाकी
तो सेमी है
जो समझदार तो यह बेस्ट केबल समझ में आया
तो क्या यूज करना है वह आपको समझ में आया
है कहा यूज करना है यह हम देखते हैं ओके
तो अभी हम सेकंड पार्ट में सबसे
इंपोर्टेंट क्या देखेंगे कि वक्त कौन से
वर्ग के साथ यूज करना कौन से रिप्लेस यू
वर्ष के साथ टुअर पहला जो पार्ट है जो
सबसे इंपोर्टेंट 99% इंपोर्टेंट है यह
पासवर्ड तो पहले होते हैं जिनके साथ हमेशा
यूज करना तो उनको हम बोलते ट्रिपल एक्स
न्यू वर्ड्स कि वह वर्क आया तो डेफिनेटली
हां यह रूप लगाओगे ही तो इसलिए जो भी
अच्छे गुण अरियां कुछ भी आप ग्रोसरी अब
देखोगे तो उसमें वह कर दी इसके साथ ही
दिखेंगी मतलब ब्रायन है तो प्रोटीन कोई
देगा इन्हीं डिस्ट्रॉयर नहीं दिया
इंटरेस्ट ईयर एंड है तो दिस इंटरेस्ट ईयर
ही देगा आपको भी वही करना है आपको यह आप
सीखोगे तो दृष्टव्य हैं इसी खोज सेंटर
श्योरन दृष्टव्य नहीं सी को एक बार मौसी
यह तो फिर यूज कर रहे हैं हम सिंपल है कि
वह आप
12 प्राइज्ड एस ए ग्रेट ब्रिटिश अपने ऊपर
के टेबल से अभिलेखों की सफाई यूज करके
देखते हैं तो आपको उल्टा इजी लगे की वाइफ
इन थे फायर और जो बोल दिया और वह राम
नेक्स्ट क्लास में सीखने वाले डोंट वरी का
और थोड़े एपिसोड में सीखने वाले हैं वह तो
मैं दिवाली की राह देखता हूं मैं इन
वेटिंग फॉर दिवाली तो वह कैसे होता है इस
पर यह मिस अवधि वाली क्योंकि इदरीश ब्रायन
है तो इस प्रयोग यह बात इमेज जरिए मिस
लगेगा इस प्रॉब्लम इस अवधि वाली तुम देखते
हो रहा दो प्रोड्यूसर फेस्टिवल में
कि वह देखता है क्या होगा हेयर ऑइल ऐड यश
और त्यौहार ट्रस्टेड इन जर्मन इस इंटरेस्ट
सीरवी मिसल फिर 2 इंच तुम इंटरेस्टेड फॉर
जर्मन में दो इंटरेस्ट डिस्ट्रिक्ट वाइज
व्हो इंटरेस्टेड है एंट्री सीरवी श्योर
क्रॉच सिंपल है बट आपको सिर्फ याद रखना है
कि वह इंटरेस्ट रिअरेंज जो है वह जिसके
साथ आता है वैसे और थोड़े वर्ग कि मैंने
आपको लिस्ट अगर आप देखोगे तो आपको अभी
साइड में दिख रही हो उसमें कुछ इंपोर्टेंट
वाले हैं बिहन मतलब हरी करना है बड़ा
नुकसान है ट्यूमर है आपको सिर्फ यह याद
रखने जब सीख रहे हो में जिस पर वह
कैंब्रिज क्यों बंदिश के साथ इनको सीख लो
और फिर आपको याद है मुझे हरी करनी है तो
इस बीमारी न समझ गए इतने सिंपल है जब यह
आएंगे उसके साथ उसका मैच दिस लगेगा अभी
दूस
का पावडर यूज नहीं होता कि कुछ बाहर कुछ
समझ में आ इधर कभी-कभार इफेक्टिव हो सकते
हो कभी कभी नहीं हो सकते बट फॉर एग्जांपल
फॉर व्हाट्स माय कार वास माय कार होता है
इस वर्ष फल मानव टो सिंपल साइड पर जर्मन
में कभी नदी में नहाता हूं को बोल सकते हो
मैं खुद को धोता हूं इस वर्ष हम भी इस वंश
वृद्धि कुंवर एंड मर्डर की नीति
मुजफ्फरनगर
आपके पर्स में लॉजिकल कि वह आप ही इसमें
करती इसलिए इस वर्ष हम शुरुआत और अगर
एक्सेप्ट यू अभी मैं आपको लेता हूं तो
आपको इजी लगेगा कि देखो अभी मैं कपड़े
पहनता हूं या फिर मैं कपड़े पहनता हूं मैं
अपने पहला किसको खुद को ही रहेगी तो जर्मन
में होता है वह अंदर यह नहर टूटने वाला
इसलिए क्या होगा इस रिवर मिशाल मैं खुद को
कपड़े करना था ड्राइड ड्रेस मैसेज पर आकर
उसी में अगर आप खुद को स्वेटर पहना रहे हो
तो पहला कौन रहा है आ
आप क्या कहना रहे हो वेटर भक्तों स्वेटर
हो गया आपको सेटिंग पर कि से पहनाकर मुझे
है तो मैं क्या हो गया डाट यह इसीलिए उन
इस वृहद मीडिया थे और फूल व ऑन
कि आइटम इन इत्सेल्फ बट कन्फ्यूजिंग मे
कंपलीटली अंडरस्टैंड है पर आप यूज कर रहे
हो यह जूलॉजिकल एक तो वैसे यूज नहीं करोगे
अगर करोगे तो भी और लॉजिकली करें कि आने
वाला है अपने लिए इंपॉर्टेंट किया था कि
जो रूल ओवर थे प्रोटेक्टिव waste वह आपके
लिए इंपोर्टेंट है और अच्छी बात है तक यह
जो रूल एक्टिव से ना ऑलमोस्ट ऑल आफ थम थम
विद एनी वेयर प्रेजेंटेड और जैसे हमने
देखा था प्लेट यह एक जैसे ही है तो उसका
टेंशन लेने की जरूरत नहीं कि दास्तां बीच
सेंटर से रमेश इसलिए आई लव मिक्स करते जाओ
कुछ समझ में है तो देखो अगर एसिड अभी अगर
जैसे मैंने बोला था कि अभी इस एंट्री
अरमेच्योर डॉयच मैं तो इंटरेस्ट धर्मनिष्ठ
कहां से आया इलॉजिकल लगता है पर है तो है
अगर एसिड कुछ जगह पर थोड़ा मैजिक साइड में
रखना पड़ता है जर्मन में दिस इंप्रेस हो
रहा है तो है योग जस्ट रिमेंबर दैट वह
बेब्लेड तो जस्ट मिट्टी रिवाइज करते हैं
कि हमने पहले क्या बोलना कि वजह से
इंग्लिश में मैच्योर सफेद था वैसे यह भी
होता है तो मैसेज को सेंड के लिए जो टेबल
था वह आपने देखा हमने बोला कि भई यह तो इस
मिश्रण का टेबल है उसको थोड़ा सा फालतू
इजी कर दिया कि एग्जाम है तो देश को ठीक
है फिर हमने देखा कि दो टाइप के वर्ड्स
रिफ्लेक्ट शिव ए ट्रू एक पार्सल थ्रू है
वह मैं तो क्या आपको जो लिस्ट को फिर से
भी दिख रही होगी इस पर मदद स्क्रीन पर तो
जो यह तो आपको याद रखने हैं कि बाकि फ्राई
नहीं करना जिस प्रॉब्लम नहीं याद रखना
है और फिर जब यूज करना तो इस पर हमेशा जो
दूसरा दृश्य आओ अखरोट या पिंपल और कुछ ऐसे
बोलते हैं कि जो कभी वृक्ष
कि वह तो आप उसको जो अदरक उसका यूज है उस
कि इंपॉर्टेंट अ प्रूफ फ्लैक्सिबल मुझे
आशा है कि आपको यह अंतर समझ में आई होगी
हम मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में धन्यवाद